i'm going to show you something that
doesn't pass the bechtel test i'm going
to show you 1994
toy fair performance now i'm not going
to tell you who it is
but i want i want you to tell me if you
can if you can
if you can if you can figure out who
this gentleman is
what are we looking at we're looking at
boomer
this is boomer he's got the biggest
mouth of them all he's the whale shark
say hello to that round mound of pound
and his power slam
very deadly he loves to tenderize the
competition before he eats him
then we've got sledge
the hammerhead sledge the hammerhead
loves to floor the competition with the
flying headbutt
did we figure out who it is do we know
who this gentleman is yet
he's got the biggest mouth of them all
he's the whale shark
say hello to that round mound of pound
and his power slam
very deadly
[Music]
sharks [ __ ] remember street sharks
he loves to tenderize the competition
before he eats them
ven diesel baby ven diesel playing with
street sharks
then we've got sledge
the hammerhead sledge the hammerhead
loves to floor the competition with the
flying headbutt
so he like shoots his eyes at you
wouldn't he be dead
you got me he's the leader of the street
sharks
he's a great warrior he's got the feels
real shark skin and he's
his special power is that a ninja turtle
with troll hair are they maki they're
make they're making fun of ninja turtles
i think
is the right hand roundhouse punch he
sends a competition to a watery grave
boom death
he's wearing a shark tooth on top of all
that he's wearing a shark tooth necklace
uh james curran don't forget royce
points don't forget
uh royce don't forget points in
advertising which usually equal the
budget so about 100 million budget for a
wrinkle in time 200 million yeah i know
that's not even counting the
advertisement and stuff you're right
tell you i want to show you something up
close and personal i've got something
here with such fantastic detail it's
going to be fantastic
see because they're sharks
blow you away head shark
doesn't matter if you shark woods by an
inch or a mile
you never had your shark
look i'm not gonna judge people with
puppets okay
i am not going to to judge anybody with
puppets
so ven diesel you gotta pass on me here
my friend
rocky balboa action
i'm wondering it was a toy fair but like
what was this for
uh vince diesel is night at the outpost
i mean
yeah kind of he's kind of dressed out
posty i would say that yeah
he's dressed quite outposty
right yeah he's pc he's there he's about
there